presque 200 milliards en neuf ans et la
bagatelle dépensés par l'état et donc
par les français pour rendre l'hexagone
plus vers un budget alloué à la
transition énergétique française qui
double entre 2012 et 2021
le cabinet ihs 4 ce1 think tank voué à
la recherche sur l'économie du climat et
qui conseille notamment nos décideurs
français a analysé une décennie de
dépenses budgétaires et fiscales en
faveur du climat
on apprend par exemple que l'état a
dépensé 37 milliards d'euros en neuf ans
en aide à la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments
sauf que comme le rapporte le média
d'information slate la cour des comptes
avait déjà jugé sévèrement l'efficacité
de ses investissements
si les dépenses fiscales relatives au
logement semble donc contribué un grand
nombre de rénovations
elles s'avèrent peu performantes du
point de vue énergétique
au cours de la période 2009 2016
la consommation totale d'énergie a décru
de 1 % alors que l'objectif est une
baisse de 38% d'ici 2020 le rapport a
également quantifier les aides à
l'acquisition de véhicules dits propres
notamment la prime à la conversion des
véhicules polluants qui s'élèvent à
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
par an depuis 2000 18 là aussi avec un
certain gâchis
la prime à la conversion est aujourd'hui
ouverte à des véhicules fortement
émetteurs de co2 jusqu'à 137 grammes de
co2 par kilomètre la ola toxo nomi
européenne des activités durables estime
qu'un véhicule et bas carbone
si des mets moins de 50 grammes co2 par
kilomètre conséquence directe l'impact
de cette prime semble avoir été très
faible sur les émissions de co2 des
véhicules achetés
et que dire des critères d'attribution
des aides aux véhicules hybrides pour
lesquels les niveaux réels des missions
sont jusqu'à quatre fois supérieurs aux
émissions mesurées lors des tests
protocolaire au global la france est
loin d'atteindre ses objectifs climat et
a même dû revoir sa stratégie bas
carbone pour la période 2010 9 2023
l'empreinte carbone par habitant de
l'hexagone est certes inférieur à la
moyenne européenne mais bien supérieur à
la moyenne mondiale
cette empreinte par habitant n'a baissé
que de 5 % seulement entre 2010 et 2019
l'explication elle peut être que
l'économie est par nature émettrices de
gaz à effet de serre preuve en est le co
vide a drastiquement réduit l'activité
en france et dans le monde et donc les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre selon
une étude américaine
d'ailleurs voici les variations du pib
mondial depuis 1960
et voici maintenant les variations des
gaz à effet de serre si vous voyez une
corrélation et bien c'est normal
conclusion au delà des milliards aux
mesures fiscales censées faire baisser
l'impact énergétique de l'économie
la solution la plus efficace à
l'avènement d'une économie plus verte et
bien c'est une croissance dans le rouge
dans un monde qui génère toujours plus
de rivalité économique
pas étonnant que la plupart des
velléités écologique ne soient que des
voeux pieux de la part des gouvernements